it must feel good right to be morally
indig
morally righteous and wield righteous
indignation watching down the street
with a bunch of people telling you and
patting you on the back how right you
are and how smart you are
knowing that all the corporations
support you and the government supports
you and you are on the right side of
history
and that throwing that brick ooh just
crunching into that face
that face of the other the evil they
love it
it feels good to them they're attacking
symbols to make themselves feel
good and they get pat on the back for it
so it's it's funny because
they often talk about right wing love
bombs have you guys heard about
what right right wing love bombs are i
have not the the idea is that someone
will go on social media
and that's what the left calls it which
says a lot about the left
and you'll get a person and they'll say
something like i think donald trump is
just not that bad
and immediately all the trump servers
are like you're so cool you're so smart
that's so rational so reasonable
it feels good you're getting all this
love and attention and then you go oh
i think he's actually cool and then
they're like oh that's even better
you're so much smarter than we thought
and then you're like he's actually the
best and they're like oh you are so
amazing you're the best
the left does the opposite they hate
bomb
like that's their strategy hate bombing
you go on and you say i think not trump
isn't that bad
why are you a bigot what's wrong with
you racist you better get on your knees
some people are are coerced by that some
people
are recruited by that saying i don't
like the way this feels
they're being mean to me no no no i
agree with you you're right please don't
be mean anymore
and now they're angry they're forced
into this they don't
understand they're just mad and it
reminds me kind of like hazing
right so why do people at colleges or
high schools haze
freshmen new you know newcomers they
went through it
now it's my turn right that's to build a
shared experience in a common line i
mean some of this has
emotions so like hurting people making
them drink themselves
to death or have sex with animals or
whatever that's that that's the
subject that's whack i mean like the
stuff you hear about
making somebody making somebody you know
stripped out of their boxers and jumping
a potato sack is one thing
but i'm talking about like there was one
thing that happened in illinois where
they they all like took a dump all these
women took a dump in a dumpster
and then made like the women like put it
over their heads or something like just
really
weird humiliation like serious power
hierarchy what was happening was that
every time someone got hazed in an
extreme way it
it traumatized and made them angry so
then they wanted to repeat it
and feel that power kids i mean that's a
lot about child abuse
in the cycle of abuse that's kind of
what we're in right now
it's like it seems feels like a
political cycle of abuse
these these these people in my opinion
feel like they've been abused and now
they want to feel good being the abuser
and they don't care who they take it out
on
small business owners random people you
know living in the neighborhood
buildings
you look at what happened journalists
reporters whatever they can justify
and on the other side this is the funny
thing you know we had uh
wash there the other day he did make a
good point but it the point wasn't
i think what he would what he thought it
was he said that
the left doesn't have the kind of
fervent militia or like far right
support of the of their leaders that the
right does
so like on the right there are
right-wing militia groups
there are groups like the proud boys
that are overtly like yelling trump and
cheering and jumping up and down
antifa does not like joe biden they want
joe biden because joe biden will
capitulate to them in some capacity
but they despise him so that's a good
point as they should
but that also means that if trump came
out
was like stop then they'd be like
okay whereas antifa goes shut your mouth
biden and they go around smashing and
destroying things again
so the left does have its violent
apparatus rage and anger
and it's it's the ideology that's
fueling a lot of the anger
is supported by the mainstream
corporations and all these institutions
and colleges
and i mean just to put it bluntly i
think all that just gets worth worse
under biden
or at the very least it's empowered
their id their ideology
well it's it's not only supported by the
institutions and and corp
and corporations and academia and
whatever but by the municipalities
themselves
when you've got the mayors of washington
dc and new york city
uh putting you know planting black lives
matter on the street changing street
names to black lives matter plaza like
they did in washington
dc dude it's crazy it's crazy they named
that street at 16th and age in
washington dc right across from
lafayette square
in the white house they named it black
lives matter plaza because
just a few nights ago there was a riot
there and they destroyed the buildings
and
they set the churches on fire hit the
cops with bricks
got you know chased people around and
were violent and like they celebrated it
by naming the street after them you see
what happened to that nypd officer who
yelled
trump 2020 all right did he go suspended
suspended no pay meanwhile the officers
who took a knee were cheered and praised
morality policing when you're when your
police departments literally
show the symbol of the ideology and then
you oppress the officers who say
anything in the other direction or any
other
you know there's something to um
dictators and the power of like
benevolent like
athens was founded by a benevolent
dictator and it's not the word has taken
a new connotation where we think of dick
modern dictators as like
strong men that control through military
force but the idea of being
dictating speaking orators they're like
a good obama was a dictator he spoke a
lot he was very eloquent
trump is a dictator he gives two-hour
speeches biden's a very failed
he's not a dick not able to dictate and
dictators rally crowds
you can call it now an orator the words
kind of morphed into now orator um
and having a great one will become that
can empower and become a leader and a
good one if you are benevolent
can tell people like stand down be kind
trump
knows how to speak to his base no trump
knows how to speak to anybody if he so
chooses he's a code switcher he's an
incredible communicator
you see you catch him in these like off
moments where he's being very sociable
and fun
remember everybody loved donald trump in
2014
yep what did i say about that i didn't
what did obama was that the birth
certificate
era oh forget about that i'm just saying
leading remember
what currently if i'm wrong didn't obama
say the american dream is to be donald
trump no problem
can you google that yeah that might be a
check
that might just be a fake meme that you
know people push around because it
sounds good for trump
but it i mean people did trump i thought
he was a clown when he was going on
about obama's birth certificate yeah
oh i mean that was so ridiculous for
sure but every every he was like
everybody watching the apprentice
i remember remember when the birth civic
yeah yeah when the birth civic thing was
coming out
people were like if you load the birth
certificate into photoshop it creates
layers and i'm like to mean anything but
then you have
people like analyzing the video on
youtube and like it's fake and i'm like
do you really think if barack obama was
gonna fake it
he would he would forget to export
properly it's just come on dude i'm just
i mean if you put like pictures of you
smoking crack and doing other terrible
things on a laptop would you just like
leave it at a repair shop something it's
worth it
guys it's worse it's worse it's worse
ready for this it's so bad
from sf gate in law school obama
co-wrote a paper referring to trump as
the american dream
booyah born in the mind obama officially
endorses donald trump
wow as the american dream was funny
that's amazing
i had not heard that i can't believe i
hadn't heard that until when barack
obama was in harvard law school he once
alluded to businessman donald trump as
representing the american dream
boom that's from sf gate done certified
news
agreement because he was born into money
isn't the dream coming from nothing and
building
like an empire oh these leaders well
there's a lot there's a lot of things
you can talk about
how about his uh his it was his
grandfather started the business right
as far as i know yeah
and so isn't part of the american dream
creating
your family yeah making your family and
your children better off yeah man and
now
the american dream for a lot of people
is what people don't realize with the
american dream
when these when these migrants come here
and uh
they they cram their whole family in a
studio apartment five people
and the dad is working 16-hour days
that's the american dream
that is the american dream the dream
that you could leave a country with no
upward mobility
with class repression and dictatorship
come here
cram your entire family into a tiny
awful living space work 16 hours a day
and then your kid gets a better job then
they start a family and they get to be a
part of that wealthy american dream
people come here for capitalism they
don't come here for
socialism geez louise people can we get
this straight
i do i do love the meme where it's like
how come no one's fleeing to venezuela
and the only the only real excuse you
could typically get from socialists is
well the united states caused those
problems and it's just like
oh get lost it's like you're you're
telling me your solution is a magic
like your problem is with a magic wand a
nebulous statement doesn't mean anything
ju prove to me that the failed state of
venezuela was caused by american
influence i would like i think i thought
it was the sanctions that put too much
pressure on their government and they
couldn't
it just broke their economy but why
can't they support themselves with their
own economy i don't know why aren't they
energy independent why aren't they able
to grow their own small and they're like
a jungle
they were they were the wealthiest like
a giant pile of oil
yeah you can't extract it it's it's no
way why why can't they get extracted
yeah that's not true dude i'm there
i could be wrong so maybe i guess maybe
i can factor
my understanding it's been a long time
it's been six years that i went there
was that they nationalized the oil
industry
so that we can share all the profits
here's the good news the people of
venezuela pay like ridiculously low
costs for gasoline
it's like really really cheap and they
can't trade or do anything else
because opec won't buy their oil is that
what it is unless they
unless they take opec money yeah they
nationalize 1976. yeah it's called pede
vesa
and and they won't they take the bolivar
wait no
bolivar fuerte now i think oh is it i
don't know they keep changing
slice off like atl one of the ways opec
bullies countries with their oil is they
make them sell their oil in u.s dollars
right if they won't bow to that then
they like ostracize them they'll put
sanctions on the country and be like you
know
take our money or so what's stopping the
country from that's exactly right but
well it the the the international oil
trade is in us dollars
i don't think that that's opec's
decision yeah well
i think there's a lot more than just
opec i don't think it's decision it's
probably
you'd be better off saying i don't know
imf or something geez how deep does it
go
well international settlements yeah yeah
yeah eis so i i put it this way
i mean there's there's no reason
whether they're sanctions or not a
country should fall into into absolute
chaos or whatever because that implies
that
other countries just magically have the
ability to to be successful and grow
their own food on their own
and for some reason this country can't
do it you know what i mean well u.s
is very unique that it has such a land
mass that it can grow crops
and has oil and has uranium doesn't
explain why
venezuela has like 12 jobs in one cell
phone store
right so uh when i went to venezuela
this is like this is the easiest
anecdote i can give to people it's like
what's wrong with the country
i want to buy a cell phone i it was it
was like six people
when in the united states when you buy
something you do you walk into t-mobile
and the lady walks up to you and she's
like how can i help you i'd like that
phone she's like okay let me go grab her
from the back she walks out
pets do it's this much a month here's a
bunch of costs and you go awesome and
you sign the thing and then she types
the things in
then she puts sim card and she calls
boom you got a cell phone yeah
so good you know it was like in
venezuela i walked in
talked to the counter i had a translator
and they showed me a list of all their
phones and i said this phone
and then they gave me a piece of paper
and sent me to you know acquisitions
then i went upstairs and went to someone
show it to him i said ah okay and then
they went and came back
with with the phone then they should
then they then they pointed me with
okay gave me a slit pointed me to you
know planning then i went to another guy
and he showed me the plans then i picked
a plan then he wrote a piece of paper
gabe gave me this
sounds like the dmv dude yeah it does
i'm not kidding
i was i was laughing it took two hours
it took two hours for me to get a phone
and then the last thing was the sim card
and then finally it was the payment
and the dude who was with me i was
laughing and he was like it's crazy
right
because the government mandated these
jobs everything
slowed to a crawl and breaks and you
have people working jobs that don't do
anything but reduce
efficiency and so like he's explaining
to me
because the government has to mandate
jobs because it's because of socialism
they just figure out ways to make people
work
in some way even if it doesn't help and
so what they did was
okay everyone's got a job now even
though your job literally makes the
thing
harder to do one of the federal
reserve's goals is to give everyone jobs
even if it means one guy's digging a
hole the other guy is feeling
back up they want him working so they're
not focused on
you know the debt machine that's wants
interest well that's that's that's
that's too much like the federal reserve
does a lot of things but
to say that they're trying to do that
venezuela is literally a socialist
government that had to figure out how to
put everyone to work it's whenever
they're like jobs
i'm going to bring jobs back job jobs
like what kind of job a crappy job that
that is a guy digging a hole in the
other guy's job is phillip yeah but
what's a real
job to go murder people in another
country like what's your job jobs
doesn't mean it's good
there could be bad jobs that we need to
get rid of yeah for sure i think one of
the biggest problems we have is that we
have a bunch of jobs
that are intermediaries that don't do
anything
you know or that do damage yeah i think
that we're getting to a point where
there are a lot of jobs that are
remnants of you know a bygone era for
instance
like i'm i don't want to call anyone's
job specifically i don't want to drag
anybody over their job that i might
think
absolutely but there's a lot of jobs
that have been made obsolete by the
internet by kiosks for instance
you know fast food and stuff so when you
have a market-based economy
that responds to price signals set by
buyers and sellers then we allocate our
resources efficiently that's why we like
our system
because we are generally moving towards
efficiency even if we're not 100
efficient
we're moving towards efficiency thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we
go live don't forget to subscribe hit
the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time